This is a misconception. One day my
non-Muslim friend came and told, "Oh,
you Muslims, 80% marry four wives." 80%.
Not even 5% marry more than one. Four
wives. In my full life, I have met
millions of Muslims. I only know one or
two of them who have got four wives.
There may be more, maybe more,
but I only know two. It's not that
common. 50%. I said okay
you get me 10 people
10 people who you know in this area who
have got four wives I will give you a
million rupees I told my friend only 10
you're saying 80%. In this area there
are million Muslims. Correct. Get me
only 10 Muslims with marriage
certificate before this date when I gave
you the challenge. I've got four wives I
will give you million rupees. Then he
kept quiet. So these are exaggeration.
Polygamous marriage in India is 4.3%.
You go everywhere the average polygamy
marriage in whole world will be less
than 10%. In the Gulf country maybe 20%,
in some countries maybe less. Average
would be 10%. Maximum you want to
stretch it 15 20% or more than that
marrying more than one wife it is not
four wives there are four wives that is
the percentage very small
so these are misconceptions spread by
the media so now coming to the reason
what are the logical reasons that Islam
has permitted
some of the Muslim men to have more than
one wife
let's analyze
What are the logical reasons
that Islam has permitted some men to
have more than one wife? By nature,
if you analyze scientifically on
average, men and women, male and female
are born in equal numbers.
In the periodic age itself, in the young
age is called as pediatric age.
There are more deaths in the male
children as compared to female children
because medically
a female child is stronger than the male
child. Medically a female can fight
diseases and germs better than the male.
So in pediatric age itself
there are more deaths in the male
children as compared to female children.
So the population of female increases in
pediatic age itself if both are born in
equal numbers.
Then there are deaths due to war
due to accidents due to diseases. There
are more male dying in war in accident
and diseases as compared to female. So
today if we analyze there are more
number of females as compared to males.
Generally
if you do not interfere or do some evil
practice and if male and female are born
in equal number then the population of
female in the world from pediatic age
itself as you keep on growing the
population the percentage of women will
be more than the male. It's in few
countries like India where I come from
and China and few other country where
the female population is less. You know
why? Because there is female feticide
and female infanticide. You have big
billboards in India you know mainly in
villages saying spend 500 rupees and say
500,000 rupees that means do a test like
ultra sonography amnocentes come to know
it's a female child about her 500 rupees
and you save 500,000 in dowi in India we
have a practice that when the when the
marriage take place between man and
woman the woman gives dowi in Islam it
is opposite the man gives is ma in India
it is mainly the woman gives money okay
you want to get married you give money
to the man and depending upon if it's a
normal graduate then maybe 100,000
engineer maybe 500,000 doctor maybe 2
three million as though you're selling
herds and cattle in the marketplace
so
it is
ads
trying telling to abort and according
with the statistics
of United Nations in the year 2015 when
a report was published on the 6th of
July 2015 in Aljazira. I have not
updated the new you know because when I
give a talk I update but I was so busy
normally every time I give a talk I
update and I give the latest statistics
better. So the statistics was about 10
years old because I remember when I done
the Dava training program in 2016. So
that time I had updated. So every year
it gets updated. So in 2015 according to
UNO
the article which came on 6th of July
it said every day in India more than
7,000 fetuses are being killed
after they as female or after they born
they are killed.